[Musique]
un père mastic le plus mastoc interne le
plus pervers et après qu'il ait deux
impairs courtier aujourd'hui le nom de
la prochaine victime
yves simon chanteur écrivain journaliste
tout ça tout le monde le 16 ce n'est pas
suffisant pour les deux à plaire il faut
aller chez lui
histoire de voir et finalement à
domicile c'est quand même le meilleur
endroit et ira suspect la chambre de
madame est logique je te dis pas le tour
des toiles on va regarder ce qu'elle
mange
[Musique]
c'est là dedans
à
j'en ai marre et yvon dans l' enveloppe
lundi la dre de la planque de ben simon
un hôtel de la région
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà ça va feignasses tu fais
pratiquement tous les ans les [ __ ]
allons-y étendant simon simon ça vient
d'où ça ça vient de l'est de la france
et du un peu plus au sud aussi je veux
dire quoi ça ma mère est et je suis j'ai
mon père était acrobates joyeux mariage
et qu'elle est nominée à vie
ton père s'était pas penser à un petit
un homme sicile de fonction des français
il a fait la guerre aiguilleurs à la
sncf lacker il est derrière les trains
pendulaires
non pas du tout il fauche et des légumes
pour nourrir ma mère et moi il a posé au
fond j'ai beaucoup lutté pour hitler
allait alors prénom il va y verrez après
maurice marcel maurice maurice simon les
agenais télé ou à choisir dans la haute
marne 52 quoi est donc allé en 53 mais
oui tu es mesure 75 km 75 et tu pèses
pas de jeu de montupet 65
qu'est ce qui te plaît plus en toi mon
imagination
on s'en fout te dire c'est des conneries
des troupes d'artistes ton visage par
exemple parle de toi mon visage je vous
trouve pas terrible paraît plutôt pas
mal
c'est au lycée william plutôt pas moi
j'aime bien mes yeux rien on dit souvent
donne aux yeux est-ce qu'il plaît pas si
vous échangez l'intrigant patron ce
serait quoi dans ton visage du couple à
qu'est ce tu peux changer à changerait
le nez la bouche interview chantier
n'est plus en patates au bout si c'est
ça il un peu un portable comme depardieu
et puis la bouche comme delon là on va
bien verser un peu de culture quand même
au un peu
le journalisme que ça veut dire onanisme
ça doit être se branler je crois centric
m'en parle
un truisme c'est quoi montrer ce que
c'est répéter la même chose nous forment
une litote
qu'est ce que c'est assez éviter de dire
le mot l' unité un cacique c'est quoi ah
je sais pas à le crétin santé est bon il
dit la vérité sur un mec l'essence de
culte et les sous-vêtements taqwa la
mêlée cela j'ai inscrits ratp d'avoir
taille basse ou c'est pas le slip
steunou lourd c'est pour la slim 120 kg
à 31,400 la wii elle sent qu'elle
s'était bien ridicule à raison ces
petites années il coupe les cheveux
sinon nous ayons une copine coiffeuse
mais aucune protection adéquat sort pas
avec elle vient de couper les cheveux
avant non seulement tu l'as tu la
laisses pas non plus tout cas de couper
les cheveux gratuitement donc je la paye
tu la payes combien pour se couper les
cheveux 150 from many droit je veux pas
lors des salons de coiffure pourquoi tu
te prend pour une star c'est ça je peux
descendre dans la rue tu apportes les
filles se jettent sur toi non elle se
jette sur moi c'est terrible un border
poseuse ouais comme le titre car c'est
moi qui vous bien sûr elle agite rôle
car c'est toi qui jette sur elle peut
jamais assez mais qui fait une petit
tacle à ses clichés à c'est elle moi
aussi j'ai tendance à me jeter mais qui
continue plus des quatre titres au caire
si tu continues à laquelle tu es
toujours avec elle on me dit qu'elle
allait acheter
tout semble de police yves simon
deuxième claque brandt a déjà fumé de
l'herbe qu'elle était de fait inférieure
à 10 heures d'écouté par la droite n'ont
rien de rupture rigole de la pub te
marrer les enfants qu'ils crèvent deux
autres c'est rigolo non pas du tout cas
c'est ce que tu viens de dire que ça me
fait rire quand j'en prends alors tu en
prends tous les jours alors puisque
cette firme tous les jours que jamais
j'essaye n'avait plus jamais pris de la
gale moi j'en appellerai combien de
temps dans une fois en deux mois c'est
tout tu vois qu'on va te croire de moi
tous les jours
parlant de moi tout les soirs ouais tout
les soirs plus tôt c'est ce que pédales
et c'était quoi et tu prônes a dû cesser
de fumer
globules blancs via la meilleure et la
colombie tu connais bien alors les
depuis ta put fume un joint
non jamais mais parce que jamal pas la
fumée ça me fait tout ça te fait tousser
et la cocaïne ça fait tout ça ah non
touche bewkes a fait ça nous fait aller
à l'époux de cette fois la réponse a
fait quoi ça fait planer un peu de
passes année ce n'est pas le mot c'est
vrai qu'on me parlait il rigole pas
vraiment à l'airé non ça me fait evian
un peu style au dessus des montagnes
dans la politique maintenant oui tu as
voté pour qui en 80 chez bt pour
l'actuel président va voter pour
mitterrand a eu raison du non qui va
voter pour lui là ils se présentent pas
dans leurs variations partis qui se
présentent nous prend pas pour des cons
tu vas voter pour qui on mars 86 88 en
mars 90 ans je vais sûrement voter pour
un socialiste ont qu un socialisme mais
non on propose de passer un mois de
l'île déserte avec je marchais ou le pen
ni que les 20 mètres carrés lequel tu
choisis c'est le radeau de la méduse la
finance et donc de moi une question qui
aurait pris six mois j'aurai tombe alors
marchez vous le faites dans un mois de
l'idée est revêtue qu'elle yves
n'importe quel il a de tous les trois à
poil dans le désert vous les deux
actuels c'est comme archives le pen je
les [ __ ] tous les deux on me dit de
choisir un des deux joueuses et un jeune
en quelqu'un alors lequel le caire le
savoir qui va accepter haïti
noël t'en fais pas pour lui a laissé à
genoux les ordures à l'ehess cote alors
maintenant on te demander ce qui sera
tienne vous savez manier la balle a déjà
eu des rapports homosexuels n'ont jamais
ni avec le pen fn et le camp d'été petit
on te demande à choiseul quant à léa 12
en huit ans que les garçons comme tout
le monde mais cette fois elle a été
prise à l'aller répond que tout seul je
vous réponds je te replonge avec tout
seul jamais non jamais quant à jamais
proposé des choses mais si ça va j'ai
refusé tu plais à goven est quand même
beaucoup oui oui et les [ __ ] te connais
annonce l'admettra jamais terrible odeur
j'ai traîné mais jamais été j'avais
monté avec une feuille de nous juste
pour regarder laisse une fois nadal
était une fois où ils commettent à payer
or c'était il ya longtemps 50 francs un
enfant doit y avoir longtemps je sais
combien c'est maintenant non j'ai pas tu
sais par là tu sais sûrement ont fait
pas penser à l'excellent ou qu'on pose
des questions ici il accompagne un
endroit tu vas pas dans les buts 7 des
gouttes ou quoi avis donc cette big boss
chez dans les femmes alors trouvé tient
pas plus souvent parce que j'ai pas
d'argent tu envoies l'argent du podium
tu vas y retourner je te sais bien si tu
continues des gens il y met sur la table
de la cuisine avait pas de tomber dans
un livre sur la table de la cuisine
dans un livre je préfère les lie j'aime
bien le confort et la moquette avec moi
quelle aventure au site a bien un qui
éviterait bien mais non pas parking
l'emmener partout deux interviews dans
pareil partout un réel bonheur à vous
ils pointent getti crois oui je les
trouvais qu'il a trouvé les rencontres
et je peux vous en parler alors par
exemple tu es là pour ça et ben oui
c'est un point qu'on trouve comme ça et
on sent les réactions alors c'est assez
fois j'ai comme sa part en arrière c'est
que c'est le point de vue tu la connais
bien le monde attendait le bus d'origine
hanotaux riediens réponse à cette
question théologique tout à l'heure
descente de police c'est la but final de
maman ta fiancée à maman ouais tagro
c'est l'imaginaire ou plutôt rien ne
vaut le savoir d'attenté avec le feu les
deux et on sait bien là un point g l et
vaginales et petit haut risque pour
trouver les tac au tac
l état qu de taxer kwassa tac au tac bah
quand on l'a vu pour grattage sur le
tirage en direct sur la toile
ah ah les ordures des justes à malices
heures etienne mais bien à un produit
tous les serait-elle de la police peut
me paraît là et a mal on peut poser une
question elle adore ça et la danse elle
adore ça s'est tout récemment le plaisir
à soi et à leurs biens à des coups de
feu avant même les gouttes de la corse
et le corps dis-moi simone un grand
bazar comme toi tu pratiques encore
réalisme d'une posture on voudrait pas
du tout plu du tout donc de gainage
d'arrêter je suis avec lui que je suis
amoureuse depuis quoi je suis amoureux
ça mots que tu connais pas ça fait
combien de temps ces amours là tu
regardes pas l'air depuis cinq ans il
monte arrêter de te branler plus cinq
ans bien sonnés elle qui donne qui fait
tout elle fait tout el fellah biais de
lessive
depuis cinq ans et pascal qui se
masturbe c'est plus doivent vivre qui va
s'élancer mauvais non plus alors qu'ils
ont de quoi faire avec tout ce qui nous
a raconté bien les appuis bien dosé dans
l'arbre ton avis bon rapport c'est
plutôt combien c'est une fois par
semaine une fois par jour où il va par
mois la fréquence en moyenne répond
ouais tous les deux jours une fois tous
les deux jours
mais des fois tous les plans vacances
une fois tous les deux jours une fois
nommé le jour se fait plein d'émissions
vers la charge à la loi tout dire
qu'elle construira un coupeur soirée si
mal mais c'est super s'est superbement 5
ou super bon ça va durer combien de
temps à ton avis
des feux ça va chercher la ligne en 2
heures et 7 a coûté combien ton petit
contrôle ces salles publiques ça t'a
coûté combien la république la donne tir
a justement c'est à dire 30 mille balles
sans ressort tout ça c'est pour une
grosse carrière il ya ce normal c'est
pour une star tu dépenses combien par
mois comme je le pense je tombe pas tu
compte pas mais tu as mérité quand même
une feuille de brick 3way cadred c'est
des trucs dépensant beaucoup ça doit
être pour 3,3 au rectorat un mac il est
si tu fais intervenir ont donc ignoré
cette asuka douche
il n'y a pas de panique au jeu sa maison
par exemple à oullins buts ont tous dit
oui une place dauphine c'est à toi oui
non non c'est en location ça tu paye
combien par exemple après samba 5000
balle est à quoi comme frère mais comme
toi même je voyage beaucoup d'argent
pour une personne entre les personnes
pour quoi faire pour être soigné chez
toi tu es une bonne et c'est un homme ou
une femme a une famille c'est une femme
mais s'appelle comment pourquoi la bonne
elle s'appelle iphone even simone et
yvonne d'accord ça va ça me paraît cool
tu peux aller convient de mettre ta pépé
avant toi mais sauter combien de fois
dans twilight je n'ai rien légiste
invitez votre charmante
et plouf c'est fini prochaine descente
de police la semaine prochaine et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars 10
tubes abonnez vous je m'étais 1 pouces
bleus